the president of el salvador has just
announced that the country has now
installed 50 bitcoin atms in the united
states of america so that people can
send money send bitcoin from the states
back to el salvador without any
commission no fees no charge whatsoever
now this is absolutely revolutionary
because usually people in countries like
el salvador use western union to send
money to their family around the world
this can be expensive and there can be
massive delays news articles have
already told us that western union are
actually expected to lose over 400
million dollars a year because of
bitcoin becoming legal tender in el
salvador essentially
saving people in el salvador 400 million
dollars a year on western union fees
revolutionary